[Musique]
sele peura
oore
[Musique]
periva
salv
[Musique]
responde
ronde
lanu
LAN
vol qu
[Musique]
zāāaa
come una risposta che tui TR una
casucciaosta e libertà come un Fiore una
Fiamma una pace
M
[Musique]
m un silenzio
tumba un amore siu come un amore nele sc
su
[Musique]
m
ConA
[Musique]
ConA grande
ma
[Musique]
per comp per
comp per tu comp perch tu comp perch tu
comp Perk tu ce Perk tu ce
[Musique]
B
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
communication with
the the
anten i am a function
[Musique]
speaking loud and
clear
oh
beautiful
Emily oh
beauful Emily I need an
explanation right
[Musique]
now some good
communication
[Musique]
someh yeah
yeah I heard a stat from
the
[Musique]
about
ful
Emily
ohful Emily I need an explanation
baby right
now yeah some good
communication
someeh
someh
oh
Emily
ohful Emily I need an
explanation
B right
now yeah some good
communication
someh
[Musique]
yeah
oh yeah
[Musique]
yeaheh
yeah
[Musique]
tu Val seras pour rien mon vieux la
belle que tu sers dans tes
yeux ce n'est pas de l'amour c'est une
envie d'amour tu Vals avec une
ombre pas d'amour pas de
guitariste ta solitude est seu en piste
et le B terminé le jour fera tomber les
belles que tu tombes et le froid glacé
dur ma d'un pauvre chien fera valalser
tes
fiancé toute la nuit Teura
Balser une valse pour rien
pour
rien une valse pour rien
rien c'est pour rien que tu vas seras tu
tiens du vide dans tes
bras la chaleur que tu sens c'est celle
de ton sang qui Val dans ta veste il y a
pas d'amour il y a pas
d'orchestre tout ça se passe dans ta
tête Cendrillon a laissé au fond d'un
cendrier la cendre de ses
gestes et nous voici déjà
de pauvre chien R t cœur dans son étu t
valsé toute une nuit une valse pour rien
pour
rien une valse pour rien
[Musique]
rien
tu sera pour rien mon
vieux la belle que tu sers dans tes
yeux ça n'est pas de l'amour c'est une
envie d'amour tu
Val avec une
ombre
[Musique]
avec Nathalie Miravette au
piano
l'été comme un enfant c'est
installé sur mon
dos et c'est très lourd
àortter un enfant tout un
été sans
cigar avec
des bous en
soleil comme les enfants du mois de mai
qui
reviendront à
l'autonne après l'été
[Musique]
de74
29 ça
ira ça
[Musique]
ça
ira
çaa
[Musique]
çaa 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
[Applaudissements]
au début des années 80 je me souviens
des soirées où l'ambiance éit ch les mes
rentr au pied de regard froidr la sal
rouutour du BR sur late sur pour
les
Passos tout le monde se lev se former
des concours de danse on peu partout
improvisé je te propose voyage dans le
temps VI planète Marseille je danse le
M je
danse je danse
[Musique]
m je danse
m je dans m jusqu'à ce que la soirée
vaille une bag au fond et tout le monde
s pas fille on r que c'était nul que ça
CIT le samedi d'aprs on revenait
tellement qu'on s'emmerdait j'entends
encore le rire des filles qui
assistaient au palis des Ren toutes sur
le parking à l'intérieur pour elle
c'était Mo rose oh cousine tu tes ou je
t'explose voilà comment tu s'agg gravé
en un quart d'heure le frèrea piqué
combi tu parles à ma sœur viens avec moi
on va se filer tête à tête je vais te
fumer derrière lespray et tout
s'arranger ou se régler à la danse dit
fes tu a aucune chance et les filles mes
chaussures h un tour je frille je te
bous tu te rabille et moi je danse le M
même les voitures c'était le
t73 GM 120 petit du Grandou à la plus
grosse miette la main sur le volant avec
la moquette par soleil sur le par brise
arrière DD et Valérie écrit un gros sur
mon père la bonne époque où on sortait
la dou sur magic touch on lui collit la
bande rouge la S j'avais la nuque longoc
lap la mar
PASC sur François et déjà à la danse à
côté de personne ne touch une pille
on
dan à Marseille on
dan Paris
aussi
[Musique]
le merci d'être avec nous ce soir new
flasher action club nous sommes ensemble
pour une super soirée de bonheur music
avec un grand concours de danse ce soir
des cadeaux il y aura des
tshirts
peluch la technique Michel Le Jok c'est
bo c'est la fête c'est parti ah super
soirée on s'amuse en les fous je
danse je danse de M vous allez
comprendre écoutez bien je danse le M
par pas ctille chemise ouverte chaînne
en or qui brille des gestes il prenent
leur temps pour enchaîner les passes
qu'ils avaient élaboré dans leur
quartier c'était vraiment trop beau un
mec assuré tout le monde cri ah oui la
piste s'enfam et tous les yeux converg
les différen et des rir éclat beaucoup
disaient que no soirée était sauvage
fallit entrer avec une bte ou une hache
c'était les r des jalou et quoi qu'on en
dise nous on s'amusait beaucoup
aujourd'hui encore on peut entendre des
filles
[Musique]
dire je dan le
M
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
and and
[Musique]
and
when she walk she's like a that swings
so cool and S so gently that when she
pass
oh but so
sadly
how can he tell her he
[Musique]
L
each when to
the
[Musique]
ah and and and L girl
from and when she pass smiles but she
doesn't
see she just doesn't
see doesn't
see just doesn't see
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah on dirait de l'italien mais c'est
c'est du Brésilien c'est astr Gilberto
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
coniss
era um era dois era 100 era o mundo
chegando e ninguém que soubesse que eu
sou violeiro que me de O amor ou
dinheiro era um era dois era 100 e
vieram para me perguntar você de onde
vai de onde vem diga logo o que tem
contar parado no meio do mundo pensei
chegar meu momento olhei pro mundo e nem
via nem sombra nem sol nem
vento quem me Dar Agora eu tivesse a
Viola para
cantar quem me Dar Agora eu tiersa Viola
para
cantar
que me Dar Agora eu titivesse a Viola pr
cantar quem me der Agora eutivesse Viola
para
cantar era um era dois era 100 era o
mundo chegando e ninguém que sou que eu
sou que me d o amor dinheiro era um era
dois era 100 e vieram para me perguntar
você de onde vai de onde vem diga logo o
que tem para contar parado no meio do
mundo pensei chegar meu momento olhei
pro mundo e nem via nem sombra nem sol
nem
[Musique]
vento e me Dar Agora eu tiesse a Viola
para
cantar quem me Dar Agora eu tiveressa
Viola pr
Viola pr cantar e me Dar Agora eu
tivesse a Viola para
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cantar um cantinho
viole amor
can paraer feliz a quem se
ama muita calma para
pensar e TER tempo para
sonhar da janela vê se o cor
covado Redentor que
lindo quero a vida sempre
assim com você perto de mim até o apagar
da Velha
Chama e eu que era
triste descrente desse
mundo ao encontrar você eu
[Musique]
conheci o que é
felicidade meu amor um cantinho
violão esse amor uma
canção para fazer feliz a quem se
ama muita calma para
pensar e TER tempo para
sonhar da janela ver se o cor
covado Redentor que
lindo quero a vida sempre
assim com você perto de mim até o
apagar da Velha
Chama e eu que era
triste descrente desse
mundo ao encontrar você eu
conheci o que é
felicidade o que é
felicidade o que
felicidade meu
am Cantin
[Musique]
viol
au café rêvette un lion
devant sa
consomation il va venir une abeille vêue
d'un tailleur le noir avec le soleil une
petite merveille gr bourdonne avec
l'accent dearb et
gentimente un diabolo
grenadine
as r le
lion devant sa
consomation ilit venir un moucheron d'un
complet marron avec des ailes sur le
Tron et une mche sur le
GR avec l'accent de Marseille qui lui
casse les oreilles et lu arrive à
l'orteil
e petit je suis le
lion allez va jouer au
ballon tu peux t'éponger le front avoir
les jambes en coton ici c'est moi le
patron c'est moi qui donne le ton
tuilles tu grésill et tu tournes autour
des fille un conseil viens-toi
tranquille tu vas t'asseoir sur le
grille une fourm et tu veux te battre
avec Mi allez sois raisonnable je suis
trop
fort si tu t'en prend à lare tu finir
dans le vinaigre allez tiens-toi
tranquille sinon tu es
mort le Lion n'a rien vu
venir le mouch en
prévenir lui a mis un coup de Satan à la
pointe du menton il n'en revient pas le
lion ce n'est qu'un échantillon un coup
dans les testicules ça c'est de la part
de Jules j'aime pas tellement qu'on
bouscule quand je me rince les
mandibules cette histoire est une
fiction moi j'ai rencontré le lion je lu
ai mis c'est ridicule un coup dans les
testicules il m'a dévoré tout cru au
beau milieu de la rue je grésille je
saille et dans le dos j'ai des ailes
j'ai l'éternité au ciel grâce à mon
exploit de la
[Musique]
veille
merci
amo
[Musique]
explosãoou
sacindo a Torcida
aos minutos segundo
temp
depisada
[Musique]
CTI
tri entrou
humildade Gol GO GO
Gol FO Gol de classede
mostrou sua malícia e sua
raça foi umante verdadeiro DEA e a
ealera agradecida se canta foi um Gol de
Anjo verdadeiro Go DEA e a
g
[Musique]
se
nós gostamos de
você maravil faz faz mais um pra gente
ver pra gente ver você
ahio
[Musique]
Maravilha
nósstamos de
você Maravilha faz faz mais um pra gente
ver
[Musique]
maravha
nósstamos de você io Maravilha faz mais
um pra gente ver pra gente ver
você
Mar nósstamos de
você Maravilha faz faz mais um pra gente
[Musique]
ver
[Applaudissements]
merci comme un sans guitare comme un
château sans la Loire quand tu es pas là
je suis comme ça comme un rasta sans
pétard comme un Corse sans pétard une
normande sans
armoire comme tu es Pasin je suis sur
les pointsc mythique pornographique et
je suis comme un con je suis à faone
j'ai plus de neurone je tombe de mon
trône quand tu es pas là je n'existe pas
comme sans Salou comme Tintin sans sa h
comme un Mandin sans sa
[Musique]
cou
comme une pizza sans Oliv une page de
pub sans lessive si tu es pas là je ne
suis plus moi comme un arbre sans racine
comme le théâtre sans racine sur cette
plage sans
Aline comme tu es pas je suis sur
les tout ça je suis comme un con j'ai
montes laette qui monte je me rends plus
quand tu pas là je n'existe pas comme un
martien sansoupe comme un coiffur sans
un SC comme un pé sans
sa
bravo merci à vous trois